The hunt for Earth 2.0 is still on.
We've examined intense red dwarf systems.
Massive super-Earths.
And alien exomoons.
But so far, there's no place like home.
There are all these criteria we have to tick
off a sunlike star.
An orbit that puts it at about the right
temperature.
A solid surface, something that could retain
an atmosphere.
But a planet that appears Earth like on the
outside may not be Earth like on the inside.
One of the things that makes our world so
unique is its plate tectonics, and that
actually regulates our climate.
The Earth's climate depends on cycles of
materials like carbon dioxide and water.
Molecules move between the Earth's molten
interior and the surface through active plate
tectonics and volcanic eruptions.
These cycles help to regulate the
temperature and composition of the Earth's
atmosphere.
If we were to find another Earth like planet
out there and it had geologic activity, that
means that at least it has the means to
sustain the carbon cycle.
And all of these natural phenomenon that
makes this planet habitable and and
sustainable.
How can we know what's happening inside a
planet?
A clue can be found in vast ranges across
our world.
Mountains.
These topographical features are an indicator
that the planet is alive, and there is still
processes happening underneath its surface.
Mountain ranges are created when a planet's
tectonic plates collide.
And even though exoplanets are light years
away, astronomers could work out whether
their surfaces are smooth or covered in
peaks.
Those mountain ranges are poking out and
depending on which rotation the planet is in,
the planet will appear very slightly bigger
or very slightly smaller, depending on the
silhouette which is being cast.
These tiny changes in light could be the sign
that an exoplanet is healthy and active.
But we can only use this method when a
planet is in front of its star.
What if astronomers could use starlight
itself to determine the geology of a planet?
We think that planets form at roughly the
same sort of time that stars form, and they
all form from this same giant cloud of
material.
And so if you measure the composition of a
star, then it seems reasonable to take those
values and assume they're somewhat similar
for the planets as well.
Astronomers can work out what chemical
elements are present in the star by splitting
its light into different wavelengths.
At any planets around that star, we'll have
a similar chemical composition.
Composition is actually a really important
part of whether or not it's actually going to
be habitable. The composition really is it's
geology.
Rocky exoplanets are all made from the same
basic ingredients chemical elements like
oxygen, silicon, and aluminum.
Change the balance of ingredients and you
get very different planets.
If we have some idea of the composition of a
rocky planet, we can actually use that to
give us clues as to whether a world has or
doesn't have plate tectonics.
New research indicates that exoplanets with
too much silicon and sodium form different
types of rock than those on Earth, creating
rigid planets where plate tectonics stall and
carbon dioxide builds up with devastating
consequences.
Without active geology, we end up with maybe
a Venusian atmosphere.
That means there's a runaway greenhouse
effect.
It's gotten hotter and hotter.
Gases are baked out of the rocks.
There's no way to actually rain them back
out.
Not a good place for life at all.
At worse, the planet becomes a pressure
cooker.
Waiting to explode.
If we change the composition of a planet, it
affects its tectonic system.
That entirely changes how a planet loses
heat.
And the heat builds up and builds up and
builds up.
And then maybe there's a catastrophic
overturn of the crust.
The solid crust of the planet collapses.
Oceans of lava bubble up and the greenhouse
atmosphere boils the surface.
A violent end to a potential new home.
Clearly, you need to know about the
composition of those planets before you can
start making statements about how habitable
those worlds truly are.
But there's something else that a planet
needs to be Earth, like an invisible shield
that protects it from the dangers of space.
Providing warmth and life giving water.
An atmosphere.
The hunt for Earth 2.0 has turned up plenty
of planets.
But for a planet to be like Earth, it has to
check a lot of boxes.
If you're really looking for Earth 2.0, then
you're going to have to find a planet that's
the same mass and size as Earth, orbiting a
sunlike star at about the same distance, with
a similar atmosphere and a lot of surface
water that's in liquid form.
Good luck.
And on the list of requirements.
An exoplanet's atmosphere is critical.
It protects the planet from huge temperature
swings.
It protects the planet from small asteroid
impacts.
It protects the planet from dangerous
radiation, from space and from the star.
It is almost literally a shield around the
planet protecting us from outer space.
But it also has to be the right kind of
atmosphere.
Get it wrong and the planet can have
crushing, boiling conditions on the surface.
Look at our own solar system.
The sun's habitable zone includes three
different planets Venus, Earth, and Mars.
But Mars has a thin atmosphere and is too
cold.
Venus has too thick of an atmosphere and is
too hot.
We're the only planet that happens to be
just right.
So far, astronomers have mostly had to guess
if these exoplanets have atmospheres.
But now we're looking for them directly.
Searching for Earth like atmospheres around
Earth like planets.
This is incredibly hard to do.
So in order to to look at the details of
these atmospheres and the glare of the star
requires incredibly precise technology and
precise measurements.
Astronomers detect atmospheres by watching a
planet pass in front of the star.
A small fraction of light shines around the
edge of the planet and through the
atmosphere, where molecules like water,
hydrogen, and carbon dioxide absorb
particular wavelengths of light from the
star.
If we can see the light of the star shining
through around the planet, we can maybe
deduce some information about does it have
an atmosphere?
What are the properties of that atmosphere?
How hot is it? What's it made out of?
That's how we'll be able to determine if
things in the atmosphere might indicate that
the surface is hospitable to life.
So far, we haven't seen any exoplanets with
atmospheres that we could live in.
But that's about to change.